got bailey on the line bailey how can we
help you
hi there i just found out about a couple
months ago
that my mom had taken several credit
cards
out of my name
how did you find out bailey okay
so i um talked to my boyfriend and he's
like hey you should totally
do like a credit check and go through
like a credit report so i looked up
my credit report and it showed that i
had six
credit cards taken out of my name and i
was already
in like 16 000 worth of just credit card
debt
wow how much in credit card debt are you
now
now it's the sixteen thousand dollars
okay
so she took out debt in your name
yeah so you you do your research you get
your credit report you find this out
have you talked to your mom about it i
have
and um she
she didn't like the idea of that i knew
about it
and she was making payments previously
and then she stopped as soon as i
confronted her about it
wait a minute you ask her about it she
confirms
but then she gets mad at you and she
stopped making payments
yes yeah okay bailey how old are you
i am 21. you still live at home
i do and i go to school full-time in
murray state
okay so what your mom has done is she
committed a crime
against you like a legal crime
yeah and she also violated trust between
a mom and a daughter
that should not have happened and so i
want you to hear me say what happened
was legally wrong
and what happened was morally wrong and
you should be
justified and feeling hurt and feeling
frustrated and then when you did the
right
grown-up thing and you said hey mom
what'd you do and then she threw a
temper tantrum by not paying
her bills right right all that is a
gross violation
of everything about your relationship
and so i'm sorry bailey that sucks
yeah bail are you so you're going to
school full-time are you working
part-time at all
yeah i am working part-time okay because
what's going to happen is you're going
to start to get calls from these
collectors
yep i have okay so i mean have you
talked to them yet
okay here's the reality and uh
dr delony is correct this is uh
you have had a crime committed against
you and
you got one or two options uh you can
report it
because it is fraud you did not sign
this you'd have to complete a
police report and you'd have to walk
through the whole entire process
or the other side is is that you sit
down with your mom
and you guys devise a game plan on this
thing getting paid off
um you know another step that you can
take
is to freeze your credit that's where
you would write a letter
to each of the three credit repositories
expanding transunion
and equifax let me say that again
experian transunion and equifax
uh to close it down but you know this is
something that's going to have to be
dealt with
now i'm going to be even more direct
chris can i be even more direct
come on buddy listen um the temptation
right now for any 21 year old
is to preserve the relationship how do i
not upset mom how do i not frustrate
listen your mom
has had a gross violation of you and you
now have to treat her
like an adult that has violated your um
legal rights and your ethical rights so
you've got to
i think chris is right immediately go
freeze your
your credit so that nobody else can take
anything else on you
and i would sit down with my mom and say
you've got 48 hours
to clear this up or i'm gonna have to
report it because now i've got to get a
new social security number
i've got to get all these new things
because i can't trust my
mom you also are going to have to find a
place to live
and that's a part that you're going to
have to take on because you're now a 21
year old adult having to deal with adult
problems which means
the the home you're living in is not
going to be a safe place for you anymore
you got to go find somewhere else this
is grown up the way we say it is not by
your hand but in your lap
no you didn't do anything wrong it got
dropped on you but you got to solve this
problem
aggressively and directly well now
here's the thing going that route with
aggressive you're absolutely right you
got to find a new place to live
you may have to adjust your school plan
that's right you may have to work
full-time and go to school
part-time right and so this is the
reality of this scenario
um and for people that are out there
listening if you've never looked at your
credit report
you can get a free copy of it each year
again there are three credit
repositories out there that means three
places
that house your credit experian
transunion
and equifax you can get a free copy or
you can get a try merged copy
that's kind of got all three of those
merged into one you've got some
debts that report to experian that won't
report to equifax
so that's why i want you to see
everything john unfortunately
this is the type of thing that happens a
lot
and so that's why we talk about making
sure that you have
uh you know the right kind of protection
fraud protection
uh identity theft we have it here as a
benefit as a part of ramsey solutions
through xander
but you know out there i'm encouraging
people to really be aware
you know we're in a technological
society right now where information and
data footprints
uh are all over the place data
footprints means it's wherever you go
online they can track you that's right
okay i'm just letting you know i'm i'm
like a technical logical savant
uh i just heard that the other day uh
but anyway listen bottom line is you
want to have protection
and identity theft is there also for you
that are out there maybe you've got
parents that are aging
or maybe you have grandparents and
they're debt-free there's no reason for
them to borrow anymore
you can freeze the credit report by
writing a letter to all three of those
credit repositories i believe you can
call them now
you can call as well and that means
freezing means no one can open
credit in their name not even you you
would have to unfreeze it in order to do
that
and so again in this day and age uh this
is something you want to be aware of and
again
be very very smart and parents
don't steal from your children yeah
don't steal from your children your
children are not a backup piggy bank for
you
particularly when they're 21 years old
i don't understand this you know for bl
bless bailey's heart
like it was being paid on and now that
that she knows mom's saying
i'm done right what are you seven yeah
what she's gonna be is in jail because
if bailey presses charges
yeah bro this is beyond grand larceny
it's over a hundred dollars
huh okay this is a this is no this is
real
we're talking 16 000 16 000 theft
and so you know i'm not saying bailey's
trying to do that to her mom
right but the bottom line is is what's
the game plan don't don't try to toss me
this 16 000
rotten egg and tell me i cooked it
that's right and
don't don't throw a temper tantrum when
you get called on the carpet
you got call on the carpet it is what it
is you say i'm sorry i did something i
shouldn't have done i got in a spot i
got in the
i got messed i made i made an ethical
just like error i screwed up
i'm sorry let me make this right not hmm
then i'm not paying anymore hahaha
right sister that's not how it works man
that's not how it works
bailey man blessings to you i know this
sucks but here's
another thing you have heard i've heard
you say this and it's one i like it
you choose relationship over being right
that's right so in this
such scenario if she's gonna choose
relationship what does that look like
if if she chooses relationship and this
is what people who are
not in power this is what kids often do
because they that's that's still my mom
it's still my dad i'm just gonna be cool
i'm gonna figure out a way to pay this
off
and the guarantee is with a parent who
gets called on the carpet all parents
screw up me too
all husbands and wife screw up me too
when you get called on the carpet if the
response is repentant dude i screwed up
i'm sorry let me make this right
versus whatever's not paying that tells
me
that baileys is going to happen again
and it's going to happen again and you
are 21 you figured it out it hurts and
it
sucks and there's going to be a ripple
effect through your family but you've
got to act to protect yourself now
because the one person who's supposed to
your mom chose not to
wow this is the dave ramsey show